Okay, Michael, so that gets us to the end of
Support Vector Machines. So, let's recap. What have we learned?
>> Well, we learned that support vector machine is
not a command or a political statement. We talked about
how a margin is a, is a useful concept in
trying to understand how well a linear classifier might generalize.
>> Okay, I like that. Lemme write that down. Margins are
important. So we learned about margins In particular their relation to
generalization and overfitting.
>> Okay.
>> In particular, we, we would like, given the choice,
to find a linear separator that has the largest margin.
>> Right, right.
>> So maximizing margins.
>> Right. At least when it comes to margins, bigger is better.
>> Then we talked about how you could actually find. A linear separator
that has maximum margin. I think we turned it into a quadratic program.
>> Yes. We
found an optimization problem for finding maximum margins
and they turned out to be quadratic programming.
>> And it was the dual of the quadratic
program that showed us how, what the support vectors were.
The support vectors were the points from the input
data. That were necessary for defining that maximum margin separator.
>> Right, right. So, we actually figured out what support vectors
were. And then we tied all that in to instance based
learning and other kind of ensemble methods. And so you could sort of think of
support vector machines as being eager lazy
learners. Or only as lazy as necessary to
represent what you needed to represent. Because
the, the classifier was based on just a
subset of the data, or, or, or the raw
data was being used for defining the classifier.
>> Exactly right. Alright, so is there anything else?
>> Oh. Oh. Right. Then there was the whole
idea that, well, linear doesn't always seem like enough,
but, we can project. Data into a higher dimension space and
do the comparisons there. And that only made one little change
to the algorithm. In particular, the dot product could be turned
into some other similarity metric. And you called that the kernel trick.
>> Right.
>> love the kernel trick. And as you say,
we took, basically, X transposed Y. And generalized it to
a generic similarity function k of x comma y. And that actually
ended up representing all of our domain knowledge, which will come up
again and again throughout this course. What are the levers we have
For expressing domain knowledge. Okay so,
anything else for writing down Michiel?
>> I think you said that kernels had to satisfy the merciful condition.
>> No, no, no, mercer condition.
>> Oh,
okay, well that makes more sense.
>> The mercer condition is interestingly quite merciful, because it's
ok to use kernels that don't necessarily satisfy the mercer
condition, often in practice it still works. Okay, well good,
I think that is mostly it. So i guess we're done.
>> Wait a second. Didn't you say that you were
going to explain boosting to us? You kind of suggested maybe you'd
do that during the boosting lecture. But then you said
it would be during the SVM lecture. And now the SVM
lecture's over and we still don't know why boosting doesn't over fit.
>> Oh. That's a good point. That's a good point. I had forgotten about that.
Thank you Micheal, this is why I keep you around, to remind me about stuff
like this. Okay, let me take a moment then, just a moment. To see if
we can tie together, over fitting and
boosting about what we just learned about SVM's.